now then you're probably going to notice
more you keep spokespeople on the
television over the next few weeks
that's because of a decision by ofcom
the broadcasting regulator to treat you
get as a major party during the election
campaign just like the Conservatives
labor and the Liberal Democrats so how
is the party going to use this platform
and could it make a difference when it
comes to polling down and join now by
you Kip's campaign director and economic
spokesman Patrick O'Flynn very good
morning two more trophy let's talk the
economic side of it first of all because
this obviously is at the heart of the
debate people ittle bit confused about
you kit you know it seems to have a
Thatcherite past if I could put it that
way when it comes to the economy if you
now abandoned the austerity message no
we've said that we think the new
Treasury deficit elimination schedule as
outlined by the Chancellor in the autumn
statement which gets rid of deficit or
envisages it going by the third year of
the next parliament is a perfectly
reasonable schedule so your are an
austerity party still no I don't see
that as austerity you know they've been
a reduction now many define austerity
well I think definition you're driving
at is is if you forgive me a fairly
ludicrous one we've been running so it's
the pure economic one which is a
reduction of the deficit through tax
rises or spending cuts or a combination
of both that way you support we've been
having public sector deficits basically
every year since about 2002 even when
the economic cycle would have indicated
we should be having a surplus and much
of the blame for that was on labor in
the good times where they they jigged
around with the economic cycle and
pretended that a deficit was justified
when it wasn't and the Chancellor got up
at the beginning of 5th the Parliament
just ended and said the deficit would be
gone by now and it's still run but I
just want to ring you know because
there's a lot of job I'm just wondering
where you are on austerity because
there's a lot of talk generated by the
SNP mainly about forming an
anti-austerity alliance so join
something like that I I don't we join
anything involving that though the
nicola sturgeon is there any part of
nasty Bennett well they're a profligate
debt deficit irresponsible party on
fiscal policy and we say our MPs will be
a much-needed voice of fiscal response
bility in the next okay so much closer
to the Conservatives and that begs the
question well if the Conservatives are
ever going to actually yeah they just
said you supported that autumn statement
going to hear from George it's a very
reasonable absolutely said could you go
into coalition with them no we're not
interested in coalition's that's not
what you keeps about what you keep is
about is delivering as early as possible
that EU in out referendum that the
British public have been denied for so
long and then yes being the voice of
fiscal responsibility to make sure the
books are brought into balance and then
we can start having a little go that
enormous national debt that George
Osborne and David Cameron have virtually
doubled in five years are the you Kip
leadership absolutely ruling out because
we're in this general election campaign
people who are thinking about voting for
you could want to know you are
absolutely categorically ruling out any
coalition with the conservative ruling
out a coalition you won't see you Kip MP
sitting as ministers for David camera
but you could sit down and talk to them
we've heard that from Nigel Farage how
far would that relationship develop well
that we recognize Britain is still in a
very delicate position as regards its
economy and the stability of society and
people's jobs and income so we will be a
responsible voice in the next parliament
you know we will seek to achieve many of
the measures that we're putting forward
to the British public but the most
important things are the in our efforts
it to an end and beginning finally to
get round to paying back at some of that
enormous no ministerial roles nothing
like that that's absolutely ruled out
that's that's out of play okay last
question all these this issue of h.i.v
patients are born overseas mr farage is
claimed during the course of that debate
on Thursday what happens to these under
UK what happens to these people who are
refused treatment by the the NHS so they
then instantly deported or are they left
untreated to develop full-blown AIDS
well we've got a position that foreign
nationals coming into Britain will need
health insurance we think it's
incredibly important that resources of
the NHS are spent on the British people
and politics is all about
tough choices over the allocation of
scarce resources now all the other
parties not only a quite content to
spend money on in this case a majority
of the treatment of a very expensive
drugs going to foreign nationals and
even go to the point of saying it's vile
and disgusting to even raise the issue
now I think something like one percent
of the entire resources of NHS England
are being spent on one communicable
disease on overseas now so I'm just
working out though just the
practicalities of it all you said they
would have to have had health insurance
in the first place so they wouldn't have
got across the border they would have
been checked and found out that they
didn't have health insurance and
therefore not allowed to come well
perhaps some of them would have done but
I shall make it clear we're not talking
about retrospective changes so people
who came here legally and and were able
to get the treatment authorized under
the measures that actually the
Conservatives and lived in 2012 which
basically entitles anyone from overseas
to permanent very expensive
antiretroviral drugs you can't blame the
beat the applicant for taking the
treatment so we wouldn't be withdrawing
it all rights and the same goes I mean
we understand it sir you wanted to raise
the issue of TB people suffering from
that form over-seasoned that it goes for
people with with any serious kind of
disease that requires a lot of treatment
well I think you'll find looking across
the world at places like Australia
Canada there are you know it's not
necessary in times particularly when
public resources are under pressure you
know it's being generous with other
people's money I your own taxpayers
money isn't it not to have some sensible
conditions on who can come to our
society mm okay mr. a friend very good
to see thank you very much a d Patrick
O'Flynn there from you kit